good morning Hank it's Tuesday say
yesterday Sara and I flew to New York
City the descent was just a bit bumpy
but we landed safely drove into the city
and met up with our best friends Chris
and marina I was wearing my fancy shoes
because we were in town for the premiere
of the movie miss peregrine's home for
peculiar children got a delicious lunch
of sushi where I arrived a complete
stained my dress shirt so we headed over
to a department store where there were
too many ties to choose from if it looks
like I hate trying on clothes that's
because I do but I eventually found a
suitable shirt and then put the stain
shirt back on so as not to stain the new
one and went for a walk I love walking
in New York even in uncomfortable shoes
because you're both alone and not in a
way I find deeply satisfying even
peaceful I also love catching snippets
of strangers conversations don't you
have to like someone to love them one
young person said to another as they
walked past me we walked through an
outdoor bookstore where I sneakily sign
some copies of Looking for Alaska and
then on my way to the hotel I happened
to cross a crash-course fan what's your
name again
Carrie then I ran into Carrie big fan
Jonathan we checked into our
aggressively gold hotel room i ironed my
new shirt suited up and then got in the
elevator I then met up with ransom riggs
the author of miss Peregrine's it's all
for surfers doesn't really matter what
you say
I've known ransom for half my life like
when we were in college together we took
a road trip to the Grand Canyon with our
friend Cathy we read James Joyce
together and wrote comedy sketches
together and I was always in all of
Ransome's imagination I think ultimately
my favorite feeling isn't joy or
excitement but wonder the wonder I feel
when walking through an autumn forest
with my kid who's never before seen the
leaves turn color or the wonder I feel
when in the company of a great book or
movie hanging out with ransom always
brings me that kind of wonder because he
has such a particular and interesting
way of looking at the world and that's
also how I feel about his books they're
wonderful in the original sense of the
word after hanging out for a while and
went back to my room changed my tie and
then met up with Sarah I don't look as
nice as you do but I like oh all right I
love it and then my publisher Julie
Straus Cable dropped by and we all
headed to the movie theater for the
screening before the movie ransom and
his wife the brilliant novelist Tahereh
Mafi posed on the red carpet and I snuck
back to be among the photographers and
then I took my seat where I caught a
Magikarp
now we shall cut from the mat
to me turning on the camera after the
movie ended miss Peregrine's made me
feel the way Edward Scissorhands did
decades ago it was exciting and peculiar
and explored with great wisdom the
tension between the past you did have
the one you wanted to have and the
present you find yourself in and that's
what I kept thinking about as I watched
ransom and taaha on the red carpet after
the movie like if you'd told me 20 years
ago that this day would happen I would
have thought that's gonna be so cool
going to a movie premiere all dressed up
people taking our pictures while we hang
out with movie stars and it is cool
ransom and I have both been
astonishingly lucky in our professional
lives but the really wonderful part of
yesterday for me wasn't the movie stars
or the red carpet it was seeing a great
movie with my wife and dear friends one
of whom has known me since I was a kid
on the edge of the Grand Canyon before I
even learned to fear heights in the end
I think people make experiences
wonderful not the other way around
Hank I'll see you on Friday